[Musica]
ibrido
ibrido è una parola che negli ultimi
anni è stata di dominio quasi esclusivo
del mondo dell'auto morti dell'industria
dell'automobile tutti abbiamo imparato a
conoscere l'auto ibrida quella composta
da motore elettrico e motore termico ma
negli ultimi mesi la parola ibrido
entrata dirompente di diventata centrale
della narrativa di molte aziende del
mondo hi tech
delle grandi società di consulenza
strategica
ed infine è stata riproposta e
riproposta con grande enfasi da tutti da
tutti i media
tutti insieme con grande forza in modo
unanime senza neanche porsi troppo il
dubbio di doversi differenziale ci hanno
posto di fronte a una visione del futuro
quasi a una sentenza che recita il
futuro del lavoro è ibrido
io non so voi ma a me la parola ibrido
evoca un'attività artificiosa intrusiva
è una parola fredda che ha poco senso
quando si parla di lavoro si parla di
donne si parla di uomini infine si parla
di vita mi fa pensare a squilibri
scompensi a compromessi
ibrido non sembra essere la ricchezza
che si genera quando si incontrano le
differenze ma piuttosto mi fa pensare ad
elementi eterogenei non legati fra loro
che vengono mescolati a forza e che
quindi generano una nuova dimensione
perdendo le proprie potenzialità e
sostanzialmente perdendo cosa allora il
futuro del lavoro ibrido non so io
quando penso alla parola ibrido legata
al lavoro
guardare al futuro devo andare indietro
di circa 40 anni negli anni 70 in un
piccolo paesino della bassa mantovana lo
zio di un mio amico che si chiamava
italino aveva sì alla bottega di
barbiere che la pompa di benzina
forse in questo caso abbiamo potuto
chiamarlo un benzine re un bar binario e
se penso al lavoro e quindi al futuro la
parola ibrido mi fa pensare che sia in
realtà controcorrente rispetto a quello
che sta succedendo
il lavoro mi sembra andare sempre più
nella direzione della specializzazione
noi oggi parliamo di charles specialist
marketing specialist sales specialist
per cui devo dire che la parola ibrido
mi fa un po pensare quando parliamo di
lavoro e devo dirvi la verità mi sembra
non linguisticamente corretta e mi
suscita anche qualche qualche
preoccupazione
allora che cosa ci stanno dicendo in
realtà quando parlano del futuro del
lavoro ibrido io ho provato a leggere un
po queste comunicazioni
sostanzialmente ci dicono la stessa cosa
con due declinazioni leggermente diversa
la prima parla di hybrid workspace di
spazi di lavoro ibridi
allora anche qua mi interrogo perché
dubito e auspico che non succeda vedremo
i nostri uffici con tinello e divano
letto quindi l'unica cosa che
probabilmente
dovremo ibridare sono le nostre case le
nostre abitazioni e ce lo propongono in
questo modo studi bellissimi ben
arredati immagino che tutti voi in
platea avviate a casa vostra un angolo
di questo tipo in cui la vera ten con
massima concentrazione e con grande
serenità però penso che questa foto sia
più fedele alla realtà di quello che
avviene tutti i giorni io durante il
periodo del log dow
sono utilizzare l'asse da stiro come
scrivania
ho visto persone uomini professionisti
seduti in piccole sette le reti dei
bambini con alle spalle i poster dei
rapper la realtà mi sembra leggermente
diversa da quella che ci stanno che ci
stanno raccontato e non credo che tutti
saranno nella condizione in futuro di
avere in casa degli spazi per poter
ospitare il lavoro e lavorare in modo
attento
l'altra declinazione invece quella della
hybrid working qua la votazione è molto
più sulle piattaforme tecnologiche sulle
piattaforme di collaborazione e quindi
il video il video che diventa uno
strumento importante che va a sostituire
le nostre relazioni fisiche la nostra
dimensione virtuale
il video ci mette a disposizione la
possibilità di inter e con altre persone
senza essere fisicamente insieme e
questa è la rappresentazione adesso al
di là di del politically correct di
questa slide che come vedete
etnie e gender sono perfettamente
bilanciate rappresentate la prima cosa
che questa slide non dice perché non si
vede sotto la cinta è che dietro con gli
abiti di lavoro e confessate sono sicuro
che in sala c'è qualcuno che ha messo la
camicia e la giacca ma sotto aveva il
pantalone del pigiama
io non ho problemi a confessarlo io più
di una volta avevo la bermuda e la
camicia e la giacca mentre facevo facevo
delle video call poi ci sono una serie
di cose che secondo me non mi convincono
di questa slide la prima hanno tutti
perfette definizioni video
hanno tutti i luoghi di lavoro
meravigliosi sono tutti sorridenti e
sono tutti felici
soprattutto hanno tutti il video acceso
cosa che non succede normalmente quando
ci sono delle riunioni in video
quanti di voi hanno disattivato il
microfono
disattivato la telecamera adducendo
problemi di connessione di banda e poi
si sono messi a fare altro molto abbiamo
molto da fare il video sicuramente è uno
strumento potentissimo che ci offre la
possibilità di lavorare in modo diverso
però sicuramente non è la risposta a
tutti i problemi che abbiamo quando
parliamo di futuro del lavoro quindi la
parola work life balance che ci ha
accompagnato per circa 20 anni
sostanzialmente la mandiamo in pensione
perché l'ibrido esattamente l'opposto
l'ibrido cerca di ibridare non cerca di
trovare un equilibrio tra la nostra
dimensione privata e la nostra
dimensione professionale
e allora che cosa dobbiamo fare
ma intanto secondo me dobbiamo porci il
problema
dopo ci siamo posti il problema premente
dobbiamo fare quello che facciamo col
digitale quando entra nelle nostre
aziende facciamo unbundling e ri
bundling questo è quello che digitale fa
scompone e ricompone in un ordine nuovo
e noi che forse inconsapevolmente
abbiamo già iniziato di ibridare le
nostre vite
dobbiamo in questa fase probabilmente
scomporre e ricomporre trovando un
equilibrio nuovo che ci porti a separare
più possibilmente i livelli e perché
dobbiamo separare i livelli perché
abbiamo disperatamente bisogno di
trovare ritmo
se sono in video call con un collega con
un amico non possa essere disturbato dal
corriere che mi consegna un pacco non
posso sentire il bambino che piange e
non posso preoccuparmi se l'acqua della
pentola bolle ma non per quelle frazioni
di minuto o quei pochi minuti che ci
sottraggono a quello che stiamo facendo
semplicemente perché perdiamo ritmo e
nel lavoro abbiamo bisogno di ritmo
nella nostra vita privata abbiamo
bisogno di ritmo se siamo a cena con i
nostri amici
ecco la nostra famiglia non possiamo
ricevere chiamate di lavoro non possiamo
essere disturbati da dell'email urgenti
o presunte tali perché non è il minuto
che ci sentiamo è il ritmo che perdiamo
infatti nel calcio questo viene chiamato
fallo tattico e viene sanzionato con un
cartellino giallo
come fare
io non ho tutte le risposte però alcune
esperienze che mi sento di condividere
con voi la prima è
abbandoniamo la retorica del tubize
che cos'è la retorica del tubize faccio
un esempio quando chiami qualcuno gli
dice come vai come stai com'è andata la
tua giornata di lavoro
una risposta pontenziale famila proprio
una domanda quindi non ho neanche voglia
di parlarne
e poi c'è magari chi dice un disastro
un incubo
non ne posso più
e subito dopo segue una litania che
generalmente dice guarda mi sono alzato
stamattina alle otto e mezzo ho avuto
non sono riuscito neppure a mangiare ho
mangiato due tarallucci al volo poi ho
avuto colpo le 8 di era stato adesso il
video e mi trovo una montagna di mail di
arretrato e quindi non so che ora
finisco
allora ci sono due opzioni la prima
azione la prima opzione
se questo è vero e non succede in modo
occasionale ma succede in modo
sistematico
avete un problema e ha un grosso
problema che la vostra azienda perché
state probabilmente confondendo il
lavoro con la performance agonistica
nessun sostenere questi ritmi e se
performance agonistica perché ha fatto
sport sa che l'agonismo contempla
l'allenamento e il riposo se siete in
questa situazione
avete un problema e datevi da fare per
risolverlo se le aziende sono questa
situazione e devono sostenere le proprie
performance attraverso 12 ore di lavoro
cinque giorni a settimana di tutti i
propri collaboratori compreso poi una
parte sabato la domenica hanno
evidentemente un problema di
sostenibilità
e poi c'è una seconda ipotesi
la seconda ipotesi è che non sia del
tutto vero
che alimentiamo questo tipo di narrativa
perché amiamo raccontarci in questo modo
perché pensiamo che questo è il modo con
cui veniamo accettati e il modo con cui
vogliamo proporre agli altri noi stessi
ovvero dei lavoratori instancabili
ecco se siete nella seconda opzione
io direi che la possibilità è quella di
smettere
secondo siate molto disciplinati coinvol
stessi e soprattutto rispettosi del
tempo degli altri e questo vale
soprattutto per tutti coloro che hanno
delle dei ruoli apicali all'interno
dell'azienda non fissate riunioni alle
otto e mezza del mattino
non mettete riunioni durante il break di
pranzo non costi gli oggetti i vostri
collaboratori a rispondervi il sabato la
domenica
terzo create negli altri un'abitudine vi
dico quello che faccio io
se qualcuno mi scrive alle 13 e 30
pranzando alle sette e mezza di sera
quando sono con degli amici avere un
aperitivo a cena con la famiglia
se mi telefona io non rispondo
mando un messaggio dicendo sono
impegnato si tratti qualcosa di davvero
urgente nove volte su dieci la risposta
è no scusa non ti preoccupare ci
sentiamo domani dobbiamo creare negli
altri l'abitudine di non trovarci in
qualsiasi momento della giornata loro
sentono la necessità di chiamarci a meno
che questo non sia urgente e le urgenze
per definizione devono essere quasi
delle eccezioni se no se viviamo in uno
stato di urgenza e di emergenza facciamo
i pompieri e non facciamo un altro tipo
di lavoro
partecipate solo a riunioni in cui ci
sia un agenda in cui sia chiaro il
vostro ruolo io credo che ci sia un
eccesso di presenzialismo io vedo molte
persone che quando vengono invitate a un
meeting
partecipano senza guardare di cosa si
parla partecipano senza sapere
esattamente qual è il contributo che
possono offrire la discussione si
collegano tolgono il microfono tolgono
la videocamera è sostanzialmente
lasciano il loro nome a beneficio di chi
partecipa e si possa ricordare che loro
c'erano questo non genera valore
dobbiamo avere il coraggio di dire di no
se pensiamo che il nostro tempo non si è
investito nel migliore interesse della
nostra azienda dei nostri clienti e dei
nostri colleghi abbiamo la facoltà di
dire non partecipo e faccio altro
e infine
sostituite le riunioni di un'ora con
riunioni di 45 minuti non si può
lavorare in modo seriale dobbiamo avere
il tempo di pensare a quello di cui
abbiamo discusso il tempo per prepararci
alla riunione successiva
spostando le riunioni da un'ora a 45
minuti in una giornata sarete in grado
di costruirvi un giacimento di tempo di
circa due ore che sono tempo
estremamente prezioso
allora le parole hanno una straordinaria
forza evocano emozioni ci spingono ci
guidano io credo che dobbiamo avere
grande rispetto delle parole e quando
penso a lavoro ea futuro non voglio la
parola ibrido nel futuro del mio lavoro
io preferisco allora la parola armonioso
ben proporzionato nelle sue parti con i
livelli chiaramente separati o almeno il
più possibile
io credo che l'ibrido lo possiamo solo
subire mentre l'armonia la possiamo
costruire grazie
[Applauso]